Oh Oh see okay so I'll see something
sick
watch this out what so get what I'm
blowing off some skeletons get the
dougie teach me how to dougie teach you
Cass
ah I blew them up like hang on I try to
cast you but you guys I healed you hey
it's bear kill me Yosh I'm good heal me
healed weighed in now Bob yeah Elsa give
me your hey Marlon redstone please I
need more coal and redstone if you have
any give it give you the car you lower
bar farm you're not blogging anything I
couldn't run ruop I don't see it mark oh
[ __ ] two things go away if we try and
stare oh that's douchey you're douchey
your douchey douchey you can bind the
spell to your sword how / caste-based
buying space prayer that's what I said
to do earlier okay I got it I got it did
say that now I've got you I said those
exact words enough exactly Bobby please
give me bunch of redstone in coal is
this it we're in the arena zombie Richie
Ezio only healer ah
she's the only dealer [ __ ] okay
yes I got I got redstone now hey quick
cast a bunch of frivolous spells for no
reason what huh huh hey it's not working
and now I'm making everyone hit the
spider on tanking oh no our data King
did not work I'm [ __ ] huh I got pulled
why isn't the spider dying I you to Bob
you got he's a boss he's not just a
sweaty wait is that the bind is not
working
oh no I'm super poisoned
oh I just got thrown across the room I
did I did it's not working oh this spell
is on cool did you do the whole
right-click until you get the spell you
want yeah but he'll is not working
prayer works but he'll does not I'm kind
of he'll be able this prayer prayer is
prayer here's my you know to pray Bob
wait we're in time of crisis crisis
we've got a cornered I can't tell
anybody I'm so hurting hey let me heal
you stop moving
you're a dick bloop I held everybody but
you Wade because you're that much of a
douche you healed me twice now cuz I'm
not much of an over what what hey there
are people know I'm in the same face is
it the same thing you did I'm willing to
bet what there are people up there there
are people in the spectator box is that
were healed up
yeah zombie this is not working I'm
trying to heal people but now working
ain't now working
gosh Cass space barn space Eli did that
thank you very much oh there you are
it's working now it's working Wow beer
wield heal hey I need help there are
things everywhere attacked me I'm the
healer where are you going to love the
room alright chill out
chillax bro chillax brah now if you're
dying please shout out ah are you dying
oh boo mention uh sriracha ah he'll jaw
oh I healed Latin goddess Latin
goddesses in here oh never mind
we're being observed uh everyone healed
up everyone healed up is everybody here
old up yep we're good Diaby I knew or
redstone gofer dummy anymore ready oh
why does Latin look like a normal Miguel
your zombie red zone laughs OH
what you're just kidding okay nevermind
she's slow never mind
I like how eager you were to kill her
shut up ya dick Wow lose my gears it's a
first response dick I'll at me if you
can hear us please yet I don't think Oh
Bob you haven't mentioned that thing
that you said you were gonna mention
early on thing that I said about the new
rub the new room that I created uh-uh
new room ah come on
oh sweet baby Jesus they're here ha ha
I'm healing I'm healing
what do you mean about your slumber
party room uh not quite
Oh what the heck he made one of those I
know sounds weird
it's cooler than it is did I oughta
seems I think I did that is everybody
how are you talking about that cuz
everybody healed up everybody healed up
new bling see your juice boobs super
juice you know I realized really what
are you talking about mark you know on
teamspeak you you know you a zombie can
I give birth parents Tony Cole on Team
Fey you know you know I think the jokes
kind of ruined now too like 10 minutes
of not knowing you know yeah whatever
come on it's hilarious yeah it's
hilarious
Oh oops
okay good so wait oh I see
use the chest to share give me where
it's done I need to heal you sorry sack
of crap someone took all the food out
yeah some douche I don't have any cake
table zombie connected only me lay down
I feel like I'm missing out on my
purpose love it thank you cake cake
can't eat your cake rum cake is gone I
need more cakes Bob I hide any more
cakes people are out there oh we don't
have K help
look we're where are you okay I gotcha
healed up
oh we're gonna clear I I cleared our
side of the room
Oh don't die emotion is a griever yeah
there are many creepy nomnom more stop
moving you stupid douche oh god I hate
you so much bling bling oh no I have
another invincible skeleton oh crap
invisible zombie I got more cake now
laying down cake I put more redstone in
the chest for you make cake is down I
have a redstone Marcus yours god this
reminds me of my raiding days those were
things yes ah remember Bob remember Bob
remember we need all truths to something
I don't know that much felt well but yes
I remember huh hey you remember remember
when you were such an epic nerd hey well
that hasn't really Jane it loving that
hasn't changed
it has not changed no no I don't think
us doing this proves that you're not in
there yeah preme I have to say yeah okay
how many more rounds are there
please please music it's just a music
box I don't know what's better a
chestplate
it's a chain mail or chestplate that's
uh iron Oh Oh God I'll you thank you
he'll do the door oh yeah how many do
you need for Diamond armor six I don't
know
when did you get diamonds I have six
diamonds yeah everybody gets diamonds
they drop pretty regularly
I'm not got any of those I'm gonna go to
the middle right now and try and build
this yeah dude everyone protect me so
that I can build my armor selfishly Bob
I'm trying to heal people other than you
why you gotta be a selfish why don't you
aim somewhere else but you if you saw
what I was pointing at it's like it's
like a knuckle Conal if you kill me like
six sobbing I know I'm what shape is um
armor everything except the top
ah [ __ ] I'm one short Bobby I need more
redstone oh she could make diamond armor
with one iron bit that sucks
zombie more redstone thank you Bob
bacon make a diamond sword I don't have
a sticks yeah we don't have Rick's you
dude we have no sticks here I can make
an iron helmet for someone who wants my
helmet I don't I do I'll take it
I'm the best good Wow Oh Enderman oh
you're right who is he hitting I don't
recall ah he's hitting me oh no I got
the wrong blue blue oh no I'm trying to
heal you guys keeping you up I can't see
health bars it was like totally not Wow
Oh God by the way for everyone listening
I was like one of the best shaman
healers ever pretty much pretty much
right here guys I see him yes I can't
hit him there we go
I'm healing people here as I can I just
hope that it's enough it is says I hit
his ass why is ass I don't know seems
like a vulnerable spot pretty skinny so
his ass is a small target just saying
it's big resent being the asses extra
that I am Mars is Mars God God Oh God
why do you keep healing me I'm not dying
I'm trying to work my mojo I'm not dying
seem to get close there we go now I'm
hitting up Bobby I'm out of redstone ah
why is he here sunny why don't you just
fill my inventory with redstone please
to fill it fill it up fill it to the max
yeah that's not cheating it's no no no
yeah I know he's dead
Oh more is more I'm almost dead where I
got you I got cake I'm healing everybody
as much as possible he'll wait why am i
trapped it wait I can't I can't heal you
from here it's alright I've got full
he'll okay good bling-bling oh my god
your healer is gonna die your healer is
gonna die where are you
I've healed myself nevermind I'm good
flip them hell I need one more diamond
drop dive in your douche bags oh sorry
it's just not the way it is it's just
not the way it'd be okay I didn't put
those down I did I picked them up from
the ground are such a dick you didn't
tell me that you had cakes oh I just got
that I had cakes I put them down so
everyone could use them really are such
a dick
why who
hey it's bear my minion I like how you
handled that song yeah yeah to get in a
sword fight with him oh no oh no yeah
everyone heard it Wayne said yeah Molly
I'm so sorry hahaha we should call you
uh-huh
oh so Khloe American alright from now on
wait shall be referred to as Jade Jade
real so gate how was your day last night
I was a fabulous Oh
oh that's a fence take your calling mark
gate that's offensive
yeah okay yes let's do a I'm talking
stay I do you gotta be such a douche
Kade come on are you singling me out
because my name is gate yes absolutely
that is your name isn't it no actually I
can't even heal you Gaede that's little
hell that's cuz I just healed you
sure let's go that it is it isn't that
is the way that it is I was probably
left in this one oh we have plenty by 14
minutes I have shiny pants or sixteen I
hope you guys enjoy our mob arena battle
a shiny man's shiny pants oh you do have
shiny that those are some shiny pants
zombie can I get full diamond armor no
mark have you ever played a game
legitimately in your tire yeah sure
let's go with that I'm playing
legitimately yeah I'm the healer I
should have the most protection you guys
are douches you don't protect your
healer their healer is the one that
keeps you guys alive you don't know you
don't know you don't know I'm actually
doing pretty good up killing these guys
with my wooden sword you want a sword
ya know you saw my dad mark mark come to
the chest I put an iron sword in what
okay blah I got to rebind everything so
at least he'll deal damage now oh okay I
have full iron armor and a diamond so
got it we're good we're good
zombie I didn't get that full diamond
enchanted armor good come on come on
that's actually the whole purpose of
this arena to me
well me getting rid it's good enough we
have a crafting thing alright fine no
diamond armor just fill my inventory
with redstone said I can keep healing so
I can feel like I'm contributing to
something which I probably am not who's
using their fists nom not badass
omnivore are you using your fists
they're here
be healed oh my god he'll be very
worried I don't see you I healed myself
okay I got you
you like everybody here than everybody
healing everybody you let everybody
healing everybody get out of here
creeper oh I gotcha
here yeah mmmm Oh mark there's a some
redstone stuff about damn time
those no-rinse all of God you like this
I'm not picking anything up with iron
and like punk someone stole the redstone
someone stole the redstone
who put the place this year who put the
dime of the iron block it we could have
broken down to make stuff yeah actually
it wasn't me even a lot of sarcastically
apply me that was B build a golem how do
you build a golem I feel like that's
something you can do
yeah how do we build a golem zombie we
don't know how to do that I think he
might be lying to us Oh mark : redstone
in the chest alright what is it three
iron blocks and what and a pumpkin on
the top it depositor pumpkins it's about
like a bows it is like a boss because it
is a boss one of those douchey flying
dudes oh I hate those guys am i healing
it on me once I do this then what okay
there we go I'm healing I'm healing
again oh Jesus
come on get in the fight guys God you
suck so bad I'm trying to build this
goal and it's not working it's Lobby I
built it everything disappears I don't
know
zombie trolling us whoa hello
is everybody good on health yeah I'm on
fire but yeah trying to help but some
reason I'm not healing
oh oh I did health mark I spelled my
spells unbound cast heal got standstill
wait stand still stand still stand still
got you and got ya oh my god I made him
angry I done somebody's like Oh God
Bob's dead ah my he spells unbound
themself and I healed zombie how did I
heal zombie ah get away hates bear there
we go I got you both gotcha
sorry Bob I tried but for some reason my
spells got under Oh Oh mark what took a
mark
kill those digital gotcha thank you ah
do we have a scroll of resurrect for Bob
uh yeah no that's not your stupid Wade
understood all right is everyone alive
uh heal me
god you're so needed you're the most
demanding son of a [ __ ] yes goddamn it
stop getting in a stop moving and there
you go I hate you so much hates me the
hot damn it you does because hey it's
bear is a [ __ ] goose back
hey it's bear it's the biggest [ __ ]
there ever was yes ray I wish she could
hear you right now he will hear me I'll
be watching this video
bear is the biggest dick in ever ever
everyone comment right now on how big a
douchebag hey it's bear is here's the
biggest [ __ ] there ever was I'm not
healing anybody oh yeah
mark it mark quits I quit all right how
do I fix it again I don't like three
times more damage than [ __ ] [ __ ] patient
[ __ ] you hey honey look at this oh damn
it I have never hated anyone as much as
I hate hey square right now wait wait
did you look kids are way to look at
stats for this
yeah behind us here huh let's see
markiplier healer um damage done damn it
doesn't say human human mouth okay no
those are give any heel steps it doesn't
I don't know why my spells on look at
the damage I dealt though compared to
everybody on oh yeah
my spells just suddenly unbound
themselves but anyway I have a severe
passionate burning hatred for hey it's
bear now I want him to die in the worst
way I also took more damage than anybody
else yeah Oh barely
really Bob you're trying to be proud of
how much damage you took yeah hell all
thanks to like be upset this compared
with I'm not good at anything else
so yes yeah Oh anyway one thing I didn't
win on this kid zombie porn us back to
the island it's time to go back no Liam
all we get stuff for love for competing
look at that we do but anyway man my my
burning hatred for hey it's bear will be
perpetual and everlasting I mean I
thought I never thought that we would
replace Wade as the biggest douchebag
but it has happened and the the worst
part is hey it's bear doesn't even know
what he did that just makes me hate him
even more he doesn't maybe he does and
he's like a really bad ass and she's
nice and I've talked no we'd all gotten
the burning hatred is unreal Oh
Wade you don't even understand how much
I hate him
you're right I don't know I don't know
fly and I was in the middle [ __ ]
nowhere Tommy we need fly again you need
to go back to the Sun no we need to get
back to sled these nipples
can I get ported whack sled these
nipples for - can we get a porridge of
the T piece Lenny's nipples
I would do that every time I ever played
Minecraft Oh God oh I can't fly I'm
gonna I'm gonna like send out a tweet
hashtag Glenn DS Naples and I'm a good
kisser that should be happy what is that
both totes mixed fruit yeah some hash
tag - haha nice tag toaster scrotes ash
- Exley Sybil's hash tag douche monster
Gooch monster huge monster like oh
you're doing weird body but I like it I
like it
now don't like it hashtag masturbation
above the line line no activation Oh get
a really weird trend going this tech
masturbation
oh god that's that's the kind of people
you really want to get to know yeah
that's the kind of viewers Arendt's at
least we're trying to get your children
not to get people pregnant yeah one out
there doesn't know what that word means
should go ask your mom yeah true true
dad yeah true dad is dead he doesn't
want to do that yes mom yeah that's her
what master nation is master nation look
that's no quitter wait you're stupid
ya don't want kids you'll ask their
parents about masturbating
so I see doubt there are any
four-year-olds that watch them anyway
I'm trying to find Slendy I can't see
him I'm just floating through the island
now oh we can Billy what innocent minds
were out there before we release these
episode Lee
well [ __ ] was I just scaling a mountain
if we can fly don't know cuz you're
gonna die damn it wait no
hey it's bear what is his name wasn't in
different hats bear fights bears all
[ __ ] hates bears fault is God we hate
that guy so much right hey naina that
arena was fun is Wendy's nipple talk
would you say buh-bye I don't really
hate that guy that much she's fine no no
I said I like say arena I'd like to go
back to the arena
we hate that guy don't recording i won
back hey someone changed our penis can
into an actual pink tip
that's a pink where are you back at
Slendy I don't know how to get there
boom
I just flew god you're so helpless you
know I have insufficient funds no I
hated hey it's bear but I'm starting to
remember why I hate you so much
hey Mark one TPA accept okay two picks
ah hey some of his money teleport me
their time before next Carol port two
minutes three seconds
flip for what for a teleport look look
look look
yes Lundy must be invincible or
something cuz he's not dying you're
missing
oh hi Wade I'm missing your mere missing
I was flying right through his head why
alright probably for the best
here we wants Lindy to be here forever
right
Wow Wow I went fired my jump in the
water
let me Susie oh hey it's bears talking
he does not understand what is about to
be unleashed upon his name from about a
week from now
he doesn't know whoa seriously how long
until I get ported mark I don't know it
said like two minutes why don't you
discuss Sami deport yeah I don't want to
do that unless somebody wants to port me
okay so we got about five minutes left I
say we build something you know of
significant you know what I'm excited
about in the next yeah you know I'm
excited about in the next update no more
a special ops
more crops carrots and the word haters
also that really cool thing that we're
going to do that probably already
happened by the time this is released
it's true probably I hope you all really
enjoyed that super secret something that
we're not going to say just in case we
go on a rant whim and release all these
really yeah exactly that that thing that
was said that awesome thing an awesome
thing that did such amazing things for
everything that we're taught not talking
about we Martin belt mark felt the whole
room for it yeah I did I did he did I
did built it by hand ordered special
cables you know handcuffs attachments
you know hit and kill those what huh oh
that's a that is almost something that
Bob didn't know that thing you know you
know wait yeah Bob so yeah come over to
my house you know just good for fun why
can't I build in cilinders head anymore
I know I think he's protected anyway get
down here get down here right now get
down here right now
right now Tommy I need I need a hoe
buckets of water and they do
assorted seats cuz goddamnit I hear I
hear Bob marks in Sylmar sense though
I've got this uh yeah can we get on my
knees oh uh I already have plenty of
songs you said see ya I have seeds I
already have plenty well just ask for
see here I have seeds look how many
seeds I have here take these seeds
hey it's Lenny's nipples hey how about
that start planning them as I hold this
ground oh it
I'm ho in it I'm holding it so hard
ho around mark I am hoeing all around
everything I do is being undone I don't
know what's not being undone stop being
stupid
oh it is on my screen it's not on my
screen you're just Paulie crap whoa
plant plant plan why are you planting in
the same spot plant man it's a rice
paddy get it there's multiple levels and
it's tiered and it's supposed to be in
water but these aren't Oh get to work
Bob get to work I don't know where you
are where where all the wheat is being
planted God God boys are growing weed
yeah yeah no wait no what legal weed to
wheat uh legal legal we we legalize no
no eagle-eyes it zombie we each need a
flint and steel zombie we need to light
our wheat zombie we need so much TNT I
think it's time for the finale
wait all right we haven't done a finale
in a long time that's true I still don't
know where you are
zombie if you give me TNT zombie I'll
just cover the entire island peanut mana
fanatic until I find them
God wait you ruin every good thing we
ever have has awful I mean I hate you I
hate you more than hey it's fair right
now and that's pretty are I look good I
wanted my title back God thank you so
much a zombie about all that finale TNT
about that I have hominoid the mark give
it to everyone but mark please I am
loaded with TNT wow this is like serious
tilt feel here that's a lot of wheat oh
[ __ ]
I'm in the rain forest I kind of wish
this great grass was oh you're on the
ground
oh it's watered now but anyways I'm not
in the rain forest tombi we have one
minute we have one minute left
Don by Sunday them Tommy can you port
Bobby's and also cuz it's hey Mark
hey it's Bear wants you to know about PA
Western god I hate you so much hey bear
whoa and you won't Marga are we just
trying to define Tamar a week from now
mark our T&T does turn into TNT Oh or
are we just I see it now alright T&T
turn into we turn into TNT in the weeds
of titi that didn't make any sense lion
what I've been saying I don't what why
not bless the aborted I'll give you all
my gold oh no oh yeah oh that's yeah a
piddly looking explosion whoo oh wow
why am I getting hurt
uh-uh seriously I hate you guys
oh man I just told hey it's bear that
was the coolest thing we've ever seen
her done and all that was lame more yeah
I just I just told hey it's bear that I
hate him more than anything so he oh my
god I'm here
hey hey Bob how you miss the explosion
actually technically out of time so
zombie was a too late on the expo tommy
was cool eight I'll be with you late
we're all out of time so thank you all
so much for watching click the
annotation for videos that I've done and
was always we will see you in the next
video
ah I was the worst buy ever
Oh Oh God oh my if so it's so awesome
hahaha
our from not being able to see anything
to insta die I think the survive god
mode I don't
or are you do I didn't wait I'm like it
inside the explosion Bob you're dead I
see you're dead dad you good Oh God
I think the server is gonna explode
anyway so now me broke thus thank you
all so much watching it as always we'll
see you thanks guys
in the next video bye bye fire buddy
Wow ya later bye bye until next time bye
bye bye